Speaker 1: It increasingly is looking like all
but a foregone conclusion that failed former
President Donald Trump will run again and will
run again, specifically because he believes and
is telling the people around him that it is the
one way that he can avoid criminal prosecution
for the things that he has done. We're going to
get in a moment to a new legal analysis of whether
Donald Trump is heading to an indictment. We're
going to get to that. But before we get to that
blockbuster new report from Rolling Stone, Trump
tells team he needs to be president again to save
himself from criminal probes. The former
president is planning on running for the
White House and away from the law. Increasingly,
it is believed Trump may even announce before
the November midterms when Donald Trump formally
declares his 2024 candidacy. He won't just be
running for another term in the White House. He'll
be running away from legal troubles, possible
criminal charges and even the specter of prison
time. In recent months, Trump has made clear to
associates with the legal protections of occupying
the Oval Office that the legal protections of
occupying the Oval Office are front of mind for
him, for people with knowledge of the situation,
tell Rolling Stone. Trump has spoken about how
when you were the president of the United States,
it is tough for politically motivated prosecutors
to get to you, says one of the sources who
discussed the issue with Trump this summer.
He says when not if he is president again,
a new Republican administration will put a
stop to the Justice Department investigation
that he views as the Biden administration
working to hit him with criminal charges or
even put him and his people in prison. Now, that
would be a pretty interesting campaign platform.
I need this job to stay out of prison. But the
craziest part of all of it, I've said before,
Trump is a symptom. But the real diseases are the
people who give him money and who vote for him. If
you just had Trump and nobody paid attention and
nobody would, we would vote for him. We wouldn't
be in the mess that we're in. Even if Trump
admitted in a fundraising email to donors, I need
you to donate so I can become president, because
otherwise they're going to put me in prison. If
you just said it that way, which is maybe what
he increasingly believes. His cult is trained to
think he's smart for committing obvious crimes and
getting away with them, or that it's all a witch
hunt and people are coming after him. They're
not actually conditioned to think critically.
Did he do anything wrong when he called and
pressured Georgia and said, I need 1100 11,780
votes. Give me a break. When he said that stuff.
It must have been because he really won, right? I
mean, they're just going after him. It's a witch
hunt. And there's a couple of different, really
important implications that it's number one, he
are a normal candidate and or a normal country.
Would never have made him the nominee in the first
place. If he had become the nominee, they never
would have elected him to the presidency
if they had elected him to the presidency
presidency. And he did the things he did. They
would have demanded him removed in a way that
elected officials could not have ignored 25th
Amendment, whatever, impeachment and removal,
and had that happened. Or either way, once the
first term is done, given the things that he did,
he would have no shot whatsoever of raising
money and getting to power again. That's not
the situation in the United States. Situation in
the United States is the Access Hollywood tape
making fun of disabled reporters? All the little
things that early would have just knocked him out,
didn't he? Consolidated support? He activated
the lowest of the low information voters,
people who were in many cases not even engaged in
politics before and built a movement around it.
And now the test will be, are they still with
him? Tens of millions are, but he doesn't need
just tens of millions. He probably needs between
65 and 85 million. Can he still get that number
and can he get it by admitting the reason that
he's running? Another aspect to this. If Trump
sees 2024 as the way to remain a free man
and maybe not literally free from prison,
but just free from being in court for the next ten
years of his life, it means he will do whatever
he feels he needs to do to destroy anybody who
gets in his way. And that includes Ron DeSantis,
that includes Greg Abbott, that includes Fox
News, which, by the way, we'll talk later,
increasingly seems to be setting themselves up to
bail on Trump and to support DeSantis. The cult
base won't turn on him. Can he build a big enough
group of gullible people to get the. Again, it's
an estimate 65 probably at this point, it's more
like 70 to 85 million votes that he would need.
What happens with the Never Trumpers? What happens
with the queue and on crazies? You've got the
Trump cultists, the old school Republicans, the
disaffected moderates, the clueless people who
just follow celebrities into politics or whatever
the case may be. All questions to which we don't
yet have answers. But the report now is Trump is
running. He may announce even before the midterms
and he doing it. And he will be doing it because
he sees it as the way to stay out of criminal
charges. The next question is, is it likely
that those criminal charges are actually coming?